هناك تصعيد متجدد في وتيره المعارك في عده
جبهات اوكراريه واستخدام مكثف لم مسيرات
التي بتتصل الى العمق الروسيه كيف يمكن
توصيف المرحله الراهنه في هذه الحرب
بفضل الدعم الغربي الى حد كبير رغم اعلان
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ان الطائرات
التي ضربت ساره توب واا زيان في القائدتين
العسكريتين هي صناعه روسيه
ولم تخفي انها همم تلقى الدعم اللوجسيا من
الله لكن هذا المتغير حقيقه متغير
ويسهل في شباب الجيش الروسي سواء داخل
الاراضي التي احتلها في اوكرانيا همم وهذا
ينقل بحكم بعد القائدتين 700 الى 800 كيلو
متر داخل العمق الروسي همم التساؤلات
كبيره حول همم قوه الدفاعات الروسيه همم
وضعف هذه الدفاعات امام هذه التي يعني تصل
الى القلب وتصل الى حتى قلب موسكو همم ان
ارادت يبدا ذلك نعم بالتالي ربما يعني كيف
قد تكون رغبه بذلك لكن الولايات المتحده
والدول الغربيه لا ترغب في ذلك هناك شق
اخر ربما في هذا التصعيد العسكري همم
تقارير همم عالميه امريكيه تحدثت عن ان
واشنطن عدلت سرا صواريخ هاي مارس لكي ربما
لتفادي ان يتم استخدامها من قبل كاف وانت
طال ربما الاراضي الروسيه همم الى اي مدى
يمكن ان تثير هذه المعلومات ربما بلبله في
هذا التصعيد الحاصل في الحرب على
الاكرانيا
الحقيقه لازال الناتو بقياده الولايات
المتحده يستخدم داخل استراتيجيه رغم
الخلاف على المستوى السياسي
المتحده الا ان هناك اصدار
الولايات المتحده على انتقام الاسلحه لا
تضرب العمق الروسي ولا تدفع روسيا
لمواقف
متشنجه ايييه وسع اطار الحرب وتفرجها خارج
همم اطار الساحل الاوكرانيه طرح قبل
الفتره همم ثلث هيمارس لا يعمل همم يواجه
مشاكل تقنيه واليوم يطرح انه كما تفضلت تم
تعديل هيمارس لا يتجاوز مسافه 80 كيلو او
اقل ذلك بمعنى كل هذه هي رسائل روسيا من
جهه وهي تاتي تنفيدا لاستراتيجيه الذي
يستهد استنزاف القوات الروسيه داخل الحدود
وصول الحرب الى مناطق اخرى
التي باتت تطال العمق الروسي
لا تملك خيارات كثيره واضح كيف جاء الرد
عبر صواريخ عاليه الدقه بين قوسين
وضربت محطات الطاقه الكهربائيه
وصلت الى مناطق لفيف غرب اوكرانيا رغم ان
في وزاره الدفاع الروسيه قبل قليل انها
همم
بالامس هذا هو الرد الروسي الذي تمتلكه
ويجب الاخذ بعين الاعتبار همم ان همم رد
الفعل الروسي مرتبط بالراي العام داخل
الخبير الامني والعسكري حتى من عمان شكرا
لك